we love to be the test dummies here at
the desk um because people write into
the show
and suggest things to us that we should
try and give a review on it and uh today
we're gonna be doing a thing we love to
do called drew's reviews
okay
this is fun okay so uh the submission
comes from uh sammy mozillio okay so
ross what is this okay so these are um
the latest jelly beans on the block just
in time for your easter basket uh it's
brock's new late night taco truck jelly
bean what
and here's what's on the menu if you
look here we have margarita uh we have
churro salsa guacamole horchata and beef
taco
okay are you going to try them i'm going
to start with the guacamole okay i'm
going to go with you here that's how i
start eating
the drip dip
mmm sort of more like chocolate yeah
mm-hmm okay what about i'm doing salsa
oh
whoa whoa
oh
i'm doing beef taco and it is um
it's beefy oh
i'm gonna do a beef taco try a salsa
this is beef
[Applause]
wow on the salsa
the beef is
where's the beef
[Applause]
and then let's do i'm gonna do churro
cause that seems safe i'm gonna like
wash it down with horchata and a
margarita
oh yeah
i'll take a margarita too at home
because the margarita just tastes like a
jelly bean that was a journey too
complete with cocktails yeah
the whole enchilada
[Applause]
all right rossi what's your star rating
review for this okay
i'm okay um i like the concept uh but
i'm gonna give the execution about four
out of five stars okay just because that
salsa was grody um
um my favorite is the horchata oh yeah
sure i give the horchata five stars
and the salsa
like uh one star and
um porchata wins i'm here for the
margarita
you know what to go nice with a
margarita yes it would well please give
us your
questions on things that we should
review right into the show at the
drewberrymore show.com we love trying
the things you ask us to and we'll try
just about anything right really well
[Music]